[Music]
hi i'm greg gutfeld along with judge
jeanine pirro jessica tarloff jesse
waters and she almost drowned at the
beach but the lifeguard threw her a
cheerio dana parino the five
all right guys
no there's no such thing as a quick one
i'm out of here thank you all very much
inspirational president biden cutting
his losses after a dumpster fire press
conference where he tried to convince
the world everything under his
leadership is just dandy the latest real
clear politics average puts him at 38
approval the lowest of his presidency so
far despite getting asked why so many
americans think the country is on the
wrong track but all he could muster up
was his usual nonsense on russia and
bogus claims about inflation
i can understand why the american people
are frustrated because of inflation but
inflation is higher in almost every
other country
prices of the pump are higher in almost
every other country we're better
positioned to deal with this than anyone
but we have a way to go
ultimately the reason why gas prices are
up
is because of russia
russia russia russia how long is it fair
to expect american drivers and drivers
around the world to pay that premium for
this war
as long as it takes so russia cannot in
fact
defeat ukraine and move beyond ukraine
jeez louise and the guy who helped obama
get elected thinks joe isn't cut out for
this line of work
when the president got into those
questions gas prices and inflation and
abortion rights there was a lot less of
that certainty a lot less of that
emphatic nature
of his initial presentation on nato
because he doesn't have great answer
and as things go south biden is being
forced to apply for the job he already
has the president has been trying to
convince democrats at fundraisers that
he is ready for 2024
arguing that he's the only one who can
beat trump
apparently jessica is hoping that trump
runs you know uh
do you believe he's running in 2024 be
honest let's pretend we're not on tv
right now we're just over at a bar
having a drink
this would not be what i would talk
about if we were just over at a bar
having a drink um i actually do think
that he is planning on running in 2024
he's an excellent house i think he does
have a strong case based on 2020 that he
is the only one who could beat trump
what's your definition of excellent
health
probably run for longer than i could yes
but you know so could a clock but you
need something with a brain yeah
i'm sorry i'm just gonna shift a little
bit here yes i think what's always
interesting when you see david axelrod
or david plouffe talking about these
things is you see the real fissures
between obama world and biden world and
they're getting a little bit of those
jabs there's still some resentment
obviously about what happened in 2016
and hillary not winning and carrying on
obama's legacy and genuine concern that
in 2024 if it is anyone but trump i
think that trump is the easiest
candidate for the democrats to beat in
2024 that we will end up losing um he is
correct though about these bad answers
and i i really don't know why biden
can't just say it's a really tough time
and it's a tough time in a lot of
countries and we don't have to compare
them you don't have to say we have you
know we're doing better than these
places you're you're over there
presenting as a unit right with your
nato allies just talk about that and
just say everyone is suffering this
can't be all russia's fault we do know
about gas production actually increasing
in the united states but just own it a
little bit and americans will smile
fondly upon that they
they're cool with the honest truth about
it um and it doesn't mean necessarily
you'll win the election but you won't
have these news cycles about being
detached from reality they're obviously
not helpful to the presidency he can't
help it though that's the problem i mean
you're asking him to change his stripes
and he could barely change his pants
jesse so here we just have him admit
okay we know that we have hyperinflation
we know that we got a crime wave we know
we have general malaise he basically
just said yeah we're in it we're we're
going to pay for a never-ending war
you're going to have to suck it up
that's pretty incredible
that's the policy his policy is to bog
russia down in ukraine and bleed them
dry they're doing great and it could
take years yes and russia is the ruble
is doing fine so
to the american driver that doesn't
sound like that's a plan to reduce gas
prices it looks like that's no plan at
all this thing is going to go on forever
his policy is basically like things are
bad
not as bad as mexico and none of it's my
fault and i have no plans to fix it you
can't tell the american people that you
can't tell the american people
inflation's bad but it's worse somewhere
else we don't live somewhere else
we live here in the united states of
america that's like saying don't worry
about crime you should see brazil yeah
we don't live in brazil we live here and
and then he keeps on saying oh well uh
you know it's russia's fault with the
gas and the inflation the fed chair last
week came out and said it's not
so he's just kind of walking right
through a blown-up talking point getting
shrapnel all in his calves and he's like
he doesn't even feel it he's oblivious
to the fact that he's making no sense at
all he's been to europe at least twice
has he ever been to a oil rig has he
ever been to the border has he ever been
to a baby formula factory
has he ever been anywhere in this
country where people say yeah that's
where you should be now he loves flying
across the atlantic and talking about
nato yeah he hasn't been our border but
he knows the ukrainian border quite well
judge
so it looks to me like we're going to be
paying for a foreign war for a long time
while we suffer gas prices aren't going
away they're going up you know what the
amazing part of it is you remember when
the president said that he was going to
be the adult in the room he uses every
excuse like a child's excuse like you
heard him say when he was asked a
question at the press conference i'm out
of here you know that's like a kid
picking up his ball on his mat and
saying i'm out of here i'm not playing
with you anymore or you know this whole
thing no he did it i didn't do it he did
it it's his fault i mean he really
forgets the fact that he gave a waiver
for the nord stream to allow russia to
get some oil and start the war i mean he
doesn't take any responsibility for that
he doesn't take any responsibility for
the fact that he is lying he's openly
lying to the american people about
everyone's inflation is worse than ours
that is a that is a fact that is
something that can be statistically
proven and you know he just says it and
he gets away with it he doesn't
understand why people aren't out there
saying joe go get him joe you're the
best you've got a depressed country
right now in the united states you've
got a fearful country you've got
families who are worried about drugs
coming through the border and you know
the the president can't even give us
good news it's like how long are we
going to have to pay these prices oh i
don't know it's all about the war it's
russia russia russia well that didn't
work for the first four years of
trump's term but so they're going to try
it again and it's not going to work but
in his defense we supported the war
ukraine so he's just given us what we
want do you want to hear
from hillary sure all right hillary what
do you think
and if he decides to run he's a sitting
president and you know would you endorse
him
look i i would endorse our sitting
president yes of course i mean you know
this is a silly question so let's go
with the person most likely to win joe
biden beat in a huge landslide victory
in the popular vote uh donald trump i
think that says a lot um what do you
think well
she's out there but also
governor pritzker of illinois he's out
there today he said uh basically that he
basically put it out on the table that
he wants to primary him that he's going
to run so the president is coming back
to the united states with not any no
good answers like there are ways to
bring down gas prices while you also
support the war in ukraine you could
drill for more here right but that's
never going to be an answer that you
provide so you actually can do that he
just won't do that instead what's the
next trip he's taking it's not to the
border it's to saudi arabia yeah and
also you have people in his
administration making a little trip down
to venezuela supposedly to talk to one
of the americans being held there but
you know we also know that they were
going to see if venezuela could start
pumping more oil
a big deal amongst democrats today is
this piece by ryan graham at the
intercept about it's called the elephant
in the zoom and it's all about the
internal fighting amongst the democrats
that's where the real political fight is
i mean they always like to talk about
the republicans but this is a fracturing
party i absolutely think that you're
going to see a primary hillary i don't
think she's going to run necessarily but
she loves to be out there yeah that's
true i went on brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now